hi World Economic Forum at Davos my name
is a booster molinero and I'm giving one
idea that I think he can drive inclusive
growth how can everyone benefit from the
global economy we need to produce much
more wealth with drastically fewer
resources how could we expect prosperity
to spread when economies from the less
developed world don't have access to
basic best business practices which have
shaped the modern world for the past
century my idea for changing the three
billion people and getting them out of
poverty and into the notion and in the
vineyard can be taught to these people
are using videos making sure that that
video is used for a purpose first of all
to influence policymakers put a TV in
every house of the developing world if
the development developed world will
provide them with the tools they will be
able to create their poor tun ting for
themselves and for others the
opportunity for inclusive growth in the
21st century will come from investing in
and empowering what I call the feminine
leadership style in our opinion the most
inclusive way to close the gap is to
share knowledge and experience two heads
are better than one and this is how we
can bridge the poverty gap there's a
three-step simple program so that's why
my goal is to create a farmville for
charity if we can absolutely close the
gap between the rich and the poor surely
we can
so I'm here on Wall Street asking folks
how can Wall Street how close a gap
between the rich and the poor so sir how
can Wall Street how close the gap
between the rich of the fourth actually
your your question is somewhat absurd on
one side the gap between the poor and
the rich can never actually really be
closed inclusive growth means expanding
our conversations it means not just
listening but collaborating discussions
about international issues imagine a
world where no one is left behind where
everyone has a voice and my voice is
heard inclusive dialogue for an
inclusive growth let's turn these 7
voice isn't to self a billion our
generation is running